bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su
flash frozen vediamo di che cosa si
tratta ho paura di vedere che cosa mi
avete consigliato i ragazzi una volta in
una [ __ ] volta vorrei capire come
cazzo fa la gente a partire sperduta
negli horror rende ragazzi e bellissima
partenza se non si sa dove siamo
comunque qualcosa mi dice che fa
abbastanza freddo fus crudo non è lo
stesso risultato ma ci si accontenta
perché noi siamo troppo frighi e ci
risvegliamo né nei frigoriferi non si sa
dove cazzo siamo cos'è sta roba bruno
sogni volanti la che non ho ancora
capito neanche cazzo disputato braccio
cioè ragazzi sto già cotto spuntano le
braccia fantastico bene così
è uno dei pochi giochi dove si vede il
braccio fantastico tanto è più magro del
mio e sono anche che un senso che hai un
accendino così giusto per riscaldarti
però ti manca la sigaretta zio quindi
non ci puoi fare un cazzo cos'è prese
tornado devo aprire la valvola perfetto
permesso che nessuno qui sono sono fa vj
o freddo o soltanto attratto ragazze
ragazzi che cazzo scuse si è spento
tutto ho sentito il rumore bruttissimo
ma non importa siamo vivi
devo andare avanti di qua perché come
come acceso prima l'accendino o che
perfetta va dicendo raga che fa un
freddo cane immagino ho attraversato
dell'acqua e sono morto
qualcosa c'è ragazzi fatemi capire io
sono morto perché ho toccato dell'acqua
e che cazzo sono la torcia mario yo un
accendino e non ho paura di usarlo piano
come come diavolo si passò qui non ci
bilancio faida comincia a
non fate commenti ragazzi non ha senso
cioè non ho capito come diavolo fatto
non vederla ma non importa perché io ho
un ace così a serve anche per rompere le
porte per dora l'esploratrice minchia
che i ragazzi devo farcela a trovare lo
shampoo perduto cos'è ho salvato
autofuoco cioè diamo fuoco ai cestini
vai così io ho un accendino ed a fuoco a
tutto
ragazzi non ho capito bene che cosa sto
andando a fare ancora ma non importa
dobbiamo resistere la cosa che ancora
cos'è quello cioè bensì benzina
ho trovato benzina allora mi sa che
mastro lindo questo non serva un cazzo
ma almeno ci pulisco i pavimenti
spero sia utile poi praga è il prefetto
l'acqua non la devo toccare mi pare
quindi passo di qua bene così mio zio ma
neanche in assassin's creed faccio sacro
mazzi è perfetto non devo dar fuoco a
sta roba affetto come si fa non mi
ricordo più
ok andiamo diamo fuoco ai cestini così
perché siamo dei vandali ragazzi devo
così si è aperta la sola sta cosa sia
per il cece della candeggina
però non ho capito a cosa serve ma non
importa se sono sto passaggio prima non
ci sia più
io piano che cazzo è successo che calmi
calmi calmi torri mio dio c'è il
ghiaccio vi vuole stuprare cazzo ragazzi
via qui a scalate di potenza vai cos'è
raga siamo morti non siamo ancora vivi
incredibilmente e capisci che una
giornata di merda quando del ghiaccio
tenta di stuprare ti io volevo soltanto
un gelato cioè mio dio se non potevi
darmelo potevi dirmi no non te lo do se
non c'è bisogno di tentare di stuprarmi
ghiaccio di merda va beh non importa
comunque andiamo avanti così la cosa che
non ho capito la notizia qua raga sta in
un frigorifero di qualche chilometro
quadrato però è al braccio scoperto cioè
prime the nudo c'è chi cazzo ci fa un
tizio nudo in un mega frigorifero non ho
capito non lo so ma va beh non importa
andiamo avanti così ci sarà qualche tipo
di mostro ghiacciato non lo so
un pokémon un idea
ragazzi animati di qua ragazzi figurine
dei parrucchieri 3 doppioni se volete li
scambio e fatemi sapere se vi mancano
delle figurine cielo dei ketchup grazie
mille sangue la crema solare a
protezione 15 in un mega frigo è la cosa
più giusta ragazze mi mancava veramente
grazie a c'è anche la luce però stai
calmo e cioè vedi vedi di star calmo
perché io non sono razzista contro il
ghiaccio dove cazzo siamo pian piano
piano lo dirò che è intasato davanti non
ory dietro ragazzi c'è qualcuno che il
che è andato in bagno ha tirato troppo
lo shampoo ne sono sicuro oddio rimane
detto stronzo corri devi arrivare al
successo prima che al cesso arrivi da
tempo che parole vai così ragazzi chi ha
tirato lo sciacquone dieta melo che chi
è che cos'è questa la merenda
c'è allora non certa fame sinceramente è
inutile che ti lamenti e mia la coca e
scopro che è tirato tula lo sciacquone
del bagno ti prende a schiaffi
non c'è nessuno io io ho sentito
qualcuno che che si lamentava prima
forse non lo sono sognato vabbè main
water sciatta così almeno non ci
inondano di stronzate e di acqua del
cesso meglio così ragazzi non ho ancora
capito che cazzo ho trovato dei
pantaloni ragazzi qualcuno serve uno dei
pantaloni perché c'è ancora la crema
solare ma perché ragazzi vi giuro su
quello che volete che scopri rocchi è
stato e gliela farò pagare perché c'è un
televisore e non ho paura di usarlo
cazzo dove siamo ora che ne dite se
metto qualcosa in televisione così
almeno abbiamo qualcosa da guardare
mentre andiamo avanti tipo tipo questo
aspettavo una trappola di ogni genere ma
non è successo niente
porca [ __ ] [ __ ]
non metto non metto niente [ __ ] la
televisione bene così ragazzi non
lasciamo stare che è meglio andiamo
avanti di qua ragazzi l'importante è
riuscire ad uscire la sto cazzo di posto
perfetto uscita
ma che cazzo è rotto le palle maledetto
ghiaccio fammi uscire di qui addio
sono vivo sono vivo sono vivo sono sono
vivo dai fuoco con perfetto ci siamo
cos'è club cateria perfetta anche la
discoteca sto parrucchiere o il gelato
un parrucchiere c'è insomma la reception
c'è la reception che bello allora
permesso io ho prenotato una stanza
voglio fare un [ __ ] reclamo dovete
accendere il riscaldamento in sto cazzo
di posto perché sennò me ne vado ok non
ho pagato una stanza d'albergo per per
morire di freddo stranzi però si può
giocare a flipper
sì magari minchia sarebbe troppo figo
c'è un amalgama che qualcosa a qualcosa
è servito
beh oddio che cazzo era lo scarico più
grosso del mondo cioè io ho tirato una
valvola che non è che ha tirato lo
sciacquone la madonna ma va bene gli
porta i butto giù vai così sia quella e
l'uscita ma non ci credo ma sta roba si
apre non lo so si apre sia aperta si è
aperto a fianco il polo nord ragazzi era
era ovviamente questo è il parrucchiere
dei pinguini in poche parole by cos'è
ragazzi non ha idea di che cosa sia
successo ma l'importante è che siamo
fuori cioè non me ne frega na minchia ci
sono delle bandiere in giro che cazzo mi
servono cos'è e finito così è bellissimo
mi è piaciuto un casino ragazzi è
praticamente la morale se se volete
prendere i gelati quando fa freddo vvv
fa male in poche parole non dovete farlo
vinto in qualche modo non si sa come
comunque treviso è piaciuto il corso il
calciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come un invito a
trovate nella descrizione senza fiori
city iscrivetevi dici facciamo un
prossimo video beh ragazzi